تستمر المظاهرات المحتجه على اجراءات كوفي
داسارما في الصين
ليوم الاخر تجمع المتظاهرون في العاصمه
بكين وفي شنغهاي ووهان يحمل الكثير منهم
اوراق بيضاء لتعبير عن السياسهم
بسبب سياسه صفر كوفيتا اثرت ثلاثه سنوات
الملايين من الصينيين من الاختبارات
الجماعيه والحجر الصحي والاغلاق المفاجئ
لمدن باكملها
نحتاج فقط الى تحديد الاشخاص الذين اتصلوا
بالمصابين هم من يحتمل ان تنقل لهم العدوى
هذا كافر لا نحتاج لفحص الحيه باكمله هذه
الدقه الكبيره ليست ضروريه
اعتقد الكثير من الاشخاص في شنغهاي لقد
فعل ذلك مع الجميع نحن ضد حبس عمال
التوصيل في شقاقهم نريد ان يتمكن الجميع
من الحصول على الادويه والطعام نحن بحاجه
لمساعدتها
حررها هؤلاء الناس في شنغهاي
تحولت المظاهرات في بعض المرات الى غضب من
الحزب الحاكم واعتقال المحتاجين وذهب
البعض الى حد دعوه
نريد حوريتنا نريد تحرير بلدنا من هذه
الاجراءات غير العادله والسخيفه
منظمه العفو الدوليه دعت بكين الى مراجعه
السياسه صفر كوفيد وحدثتها على احترام حق
تظاهر السلمي وعدم اعتقال المتظاهرين